THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE -- JUST --
TO I NEED TO ANNOUNCE THAT AB
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE BY COOLEY
WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY WILL BE
HEARD ON JUNE.
TWENTY SIX AND I SEE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE MISTER CALDERON WITH
US BUT I SEE MISS WEBER IF WOULD
YOU LIKE TO JOIN US.
AND BEFORE WE PROCEED I LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT AB TEN SIXTY FIVE
BY MISTER BERMAN HAS ALSO BEEN
PULLED.
AND WILL BE CONSIDERED AT A
LATER TIME THANK YOU.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WEBER
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU AND THE THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THE BILL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- THEY I HAVE THE
PLEASURE PRESENTING A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
CODIFIES AN EXISTING BEST
PRACTICE IN THE MARKETPLACE
TODAY.
I CLARIFYING A CONSUMERS RIGHT
TO CHOOSE EITHER A CASH PAYMENT
OR TO REPAIR THEIR VEHICLE.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IS FOUND THAT A SMALL
HANDFUL OF INSURERS HAVE A QUOTE
NO CASH OUT PROVISION IN THEIR
CONTRACTS.
IF A CONSUMER IS IN AN ACCIDENT
THAT CAUSES MODERATE DAMAGE TO
THE VEHICLE THAT CAUSES TWENTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER I'M SORRY
TO INTERRUPT IT WAS MY MISTAKE I
NEED TO ESTABLISH THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM AT THIS TIME SUCH
AS WE'RE MOVING FORWARD AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WE WILL.
OF KALRA WHEN WE DO HAVE A FULL
FORM THANK YOU SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION A PROBLEM NO
PROBLEM.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SURE
IS A SOUND THAT A SMALL HANDFUL
OF INSURERS HAVE A QUOTE NO CASH
OUT PROVISION IN THEIR CONTRACT.
IF A CONSUMER IS IN AN ACCIDENT
CAUSES MODERATE CHANGE TO THE
VEHICLE IT COSTS TWO THOUSAND TO
REPAIR AND THE CONSUMER HAS A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE.
THESE INSURANCE WHAT THEY'VE
CALLED NO CASH OUT PROVISION
REFUSED TO ISSUE THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR PAYMENT IT OWED
TO THE CONSUMER UNLESS THEY SHOW
PROOF THAT THE REPAIRS ARE BEING
MADE -- FORCING SUPPORTING A
FINANCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
CONSUMER TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
REPAIRING THEIR VEHICLE AND NOT
COLLECTING ANY CLAIM PAYMENT AT
ALL IS UNFAIR.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TROUBLING FOR
LOW INCOME DRIVERS WHO HAVE
DUTIFULLY PAY THEIR PREMIUMS ON
TIME WE NOW HAVE THE FUNDS TO
COVER THE DEDUCTIBLE AMOUNT.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THAT A
FIRST PARTY AUTOMOBILE PHYSICAL
DAMAGE PAYMENT MAY OPT TO
RECEIVE A MONETARY PAYMENT BASED
ON VALUE OF THE DAMAGE TO THE
VEHICLE.
IN LIEU OF HAVING THE VEHICLE
REPAIR.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND HERE TO SPEAK AND
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IS
MICHAEL MARTINEZ THE SENIOR.
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA.
THIS BILL HAS NO HAS RECEIVED NO --
NO VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT'S A MARTINEZ TO SHOOT.
WAS THE COMMENT YES THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL MARTINEZ
HERE BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA.
AND THINK THE THE ASSEMBLY ONE
FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND AUTHORING
THIS MEASURE AND COMMISSIONER
LARA IS VERY PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE AND AND ABSOLUTELY
WITH BUT THE AUTHOR HAD STATED
ABOUT THE BILL.
OF SOLDIERS.
SUMMER IS IN THIS WAY THAT IT
DOES.
THERE IS AN EXISTING ENSURE
PRACTICE ABOUT WHICH THE NINETY
EIGHT POINT 5% OF INSURERS THAT
CURRENTLY TO PROVIDE.
GIVE CONSUMERS THE OPTION TO
CASH OUT THEIR CLAIMS AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD HELP TO
ENSURE. FOR VERY SMALL HANDFUL
OF INSURERS AGAIN LESS ABOUT 2%.
THAT CURRENTLY HAVE THESE NO
CASH OUT PROVISIONS IN THEIR
CONTRACTS. TO TO BE ABLE TO
ALLOW THE SODA THIS A PRACTICE
FOR AGAIN FOR THAT SMALL AMOUNT
OF OF INSURANCE THAT ARE PART OF
THAT 2%.
AND SO WE FEEL ECHOES A LONG WAY
IT FOR AN EXISTING BEST PRACTICE.
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS THE SET OF
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL WITHIN GO
A LONG WAY IN HELPING TO ENSURE.
DATA A RESTORED PAYMENT IN CASES
OF SUSPECTED FRAUD THERE'S ALSO --
ALLOWS ENSURE TO INCLUDE THE
LOST PAY OR LIEN HOLDER AS AN
ADDITIONAL PAY HE ON THE
CONSUMERS CLAIM PAYMENT AS WELL
AS A THIRD SET OF AMENDMENTS.
THAT TO MAKE CLEAR THA INSURERS
CAN REQUIRE A DAMAGED VEHICLE TO
BE REPAIRED.
IN CASES WHERE THE VEHICLE
SAFETY FEATURES THAT ARE PART OF
VEHICLES OPERATING SYSTEMS ARE
COMPROMISED TO FILL THOSE ARE
REALLY GOOD CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AS WELL.
ALL AROUND AND SO WITHOUT ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN SOME.
CAN YOU GET TEARS ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HEY SEE [inaudible]
NINE IS -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANYBODY WISHING TO ASK QUESTIONS.
WE DO HAVE.
OKAY SEE WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
COMMENTS ON THIRTY WEBER WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE REALLY WHAT IT
JUST SIMPLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WE'RE LISTENING TO US TODAY AND
BILL TO A SIGNIFICANT.
POPULATION NOT ALWAYS THE
LARGEST POPULATION BUT IT'S A
FAIR AND HONEST BILL THAT THIS
SHOULD BE OFFERED TO INDIVIDUALS
AND AS POINTED OUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
MAKE IT EVEN STRONGER AND
FAIRFIELD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE BUT
WHEN YOU GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT BALANCES.
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS AS WELL
AS TAKE THE INDUSTRY INTO
ACCOUNT AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S PROTECTION FOR FRAUD.
AS YOU CAN SEE WERE STILL
LACKING A QUORUM SO WE'LL PUT
THIS PHONE CALL AND MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE'LL EMAIL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MISTER CALDERON HERE.
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A REALLY
SHORT RECESS UNFORTUNATELY I SEE
MR STEINBERG CALDERON HERE.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO BILL AB
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A TAKE
THE SUGGEST A COMMITTEE MEMON
CINEMA THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING ME MY OFFICE -- IN
TWENTY THIRTY IS PROJECTED THAT
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE A. SIXTY
FIVE WILL BECOME A LARGER SHARE
OF THE POPULATION IN CHILDREN.
UNDER EIGHTEEN MORE THAN HALF OF
THIS POPULATION WILL NEED LONG
TERM CARE SERVICES AT SOME POINT
YET THERE IS NO SUSTAINABLE.
OPTION FOR SENIORS.
WITH AND AND WITH SENIORS WITH
COGNITIVE AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES AND THERE'S NO REAL
OPTION FOR THEM TO OBTAIN A
FORMAL LONG TERM CARE SERVICES --
MIDDLE CLASS SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES MUST DECIDE
WHETHER TO SPEND ON THEIR ASSETS
IN ORDER TO PAY.
FOR OR EXHAUST THEIR PERSONAL
AFTER THE ASSETS AND PAYING
DRIVING EXPERIENCE WHEN MY
GRANDMOTHER WHEN SHE HAD
ALZHEIMER'S LIKELY YOU KNOW SHE
WAS A RIVETER -- DURING YOU KNOW
THE WAR AND AND SO SHE STICKS.
ARE SAVED A LOT OF HER MONEY WAS
ABLE TO HELP IN THOSE IN PAYING
FOR THOSE COSTS BUT WAS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
BECAUSE OF THIS AND I'M OFFERING
THIS BILL -- TO ESTABLISH A LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE TASK FORCE
CONVENED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER NOW EVER SINCE I
GOT ELECTED I'VE WORKED A LOT ON
THESE ISSUES.
WHEN IT COMES A LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE I'VE WORKED ON THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE I VERY MUCH SEEN
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE?
I LONG TERM SURE A CARE -- NOW
SERVICES AS BEING A MILLENNIAL
ISSUE AND THE REASON WHY IS THAT
MY PARENTS MY AND MY PARENTS
GENERATION MY GENERATION'S
PARENTS ARE THE ONES THAT
SUFFERED THROUGH THE RECESSION
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE MY MOTHER MY
STEPFATHER BUSINESS OWNERS.
THEY LOST EVERYTHING NOT ONLY
DID THEY LOSE OUR BUSINESS
BECAUSE OF OF THE RECESSION ALSO
LOST THEIR HOME.
AND IN THAT PROCESS TRYING TO
KEEP THE BUSINESS ALIVE THEY
SPEND DOWN ALL THEIR ASSETS ALL
THE RETIREMENT.
ABSOLUTELY EVERY SINGLE PENNY
THEY HAD BECAUSE THERE WAS NO IT
WASN'T CLEAR HOW LONG THE
RECESSION IS GOING TO LAST SO
THAT THAT THEY COULD PROP IT UP.
AND RECOUP THAT MONEY LATER ON
BUT THE RECESSION WAS SO LONG
THAT THEY ENDED UP LOSING
EVERYTHING -- ACTUALLY OTHER.
YOUR THEIR SENATOR.
CENTER BATES AND SO.
YOU KNOW THE TIME.
WE LOST PROVIDERS FOR LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE YOU KNOW WE STILL
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED PROVIDERS A
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE WHICH
WOULD HELP.
MITIGATE THE COST OF IT NOW
THERE'S TEN PROVIDERS OF LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE ENERGY
ATTENDED.
TWELVE SO THE COSTS ARE HIGHER
IT'S AND ALTERNATELY THE PROBLEM
IN THE REASON WHY CHARACTERIZES
IS VERY MUCH MILLENNIAL ISSUE IS
THAT THOSE COSTS IN THOSE BURNS
ARE GONNA FALL UPON ME IN MY
GENERATION.
WHEN WORD WE HAVE MOUNTAINS OF
STUDENT LOAN DEBT EVEN WHEN WE
GO TO COLLEGE ARE STILL ONLY
GREAT GETTING A MINIMUM WAGE
JOBS NOT BEING ABLE TO REALLY
COVER ON COSTS?
HAVING MOVED BACK IN WITH THOSE
PARENTS WERE REALLY NOT SUITABLE
SUITED TO TAKE ON THOSE COSTS.
OF PROVIDING SERVICES IN IN THE
EVENT THAT ONE OF OUR PARENTS
ARE GONNA NEED THOSE SERVICES
AND SELL.
I WANT TO SET UP THIS TASK FORCE.
THAT IT IS CONVENE BY THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER TO
PROVIDE EXPERT RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE INSURANCE COMMISSION OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE GOVERNOR ON COMPONENTS
NECESSARY TO ESTABLISH A
STATEWIDE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE PROGRAM.
IN CALIFORNIA -- SO GIVEN YOU
KNOW THE GROWING RECOGNITION OF
CALIFORNIA'S DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFTS.
IT'S WE SEE IT AS AN OPPORTUNE
TIME TO IDENTIFY STRATEGIES
AVAILABLE TO TRY TO SUCCESSFUL
PATH TO LONG TERM CARE.
STABILITY THAT SOME OF THE
MOTIVATION THIS WILL.
DO IS JUST TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
WAY THAT WE CAN CAN I GET THIS.
ARE GOING ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT'S GONNA
TAKE BECAUSE I JUST DON'T THINK
THERE'S RELIABILITY ON THE
PRIVATE SECTOR MOVING FORWARD
WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE
ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
WITH WE CREATE A PROGRAM WHAT IS
THAT LOOK LIKE -- AND I THINK A
TASK FORCE IS WHERE WE NEED TO
START BECAUSE HOW CAN WE MAKE A
DECISION WITHOUT THOROUGHLY
UNDERSTANDING AN ISSUEAND THIS
IS A GREAT WAY TO UNDERSTAND
THAT ISSUE WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
IS DELORES AROUND FLOOR AS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IT ALL COME IN THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS AGAIN I'M TO LARA STRAND
FLORES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB.
FIVE SIX SEVEN TRAGEDY CAN
STRIKE AT ANY TIME AND ANYONE
CAN FIND THEM SEE THEIR SELVES
INDEED OF LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE WHICH CAN BE
DEVASTATING FINANCIALLY.
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE IS A BIG CONCERN
FOR CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND
OTHER WORKING FAMILIES -- MY
MEMBERS EARN ON AVERAGE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
FULL TIME WORK AND THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR OR PART
TIME WORK.
AFTER PAYING FOR BASIC LIVING
EXPENSES AND HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE IS SIMPLY OUT OF REACH
FOR THEM [inaudible]
ALMOST.
THE MOST PEOPLE THINK THAT THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERS LONG
TERM CARE.
WHEN WORKERS AND THEIR LOVED
ONES CAN NO LONGER CARE FOR
THEMSELVES AND ARE EXPOSED TO
THE HIGH COST OF NURSING CARE
THEIR SHOT?
AND THEY'RE AFRAID.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE TO EXCEED SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THAT KIND
OF MONEY TO PAY NOT EVEN FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS WITHOUT WIPING
OUT THEIR SAVINGS.
AND OTHER ASSETS.
AFTER THEY HAVE NOTHING IN THEIR
SAVINGS THEY SELL THEIR HOME
THEY SELL THEIR CAR.
THEY'RE FORCED TO RELY ON THE
STATE.
AND THEIR FAMILIES FOR CARE.
THIS IS WRONG THIS IS UNFAIR IT
HAPPENED TO MY MOTHER IN LAW AS
WELL.
AS SEVERAL THOUSAND EVERY MONTH.
AND AFTER THREE MONTHS SHE WAS
OUT OF ALL OF HER MONEY -- HAD
SHE SURVIVED WE WOULD HAVE HAD
TO DISPOSE OF ALL OF HER ASSETS
TO PAY FOR HER LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE.
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN IT NEEDS TO
BE FIXED AND WE THINK AB FIVE
SIX SEVEN IS A NECESSARY STEP IN
THIS PROCESS WE ARE DR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL MARTINEZ
FROM BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND WANT TO THANK.
THE ASSEMBLYMAN FOR OFFERING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE IS IS --
A GROWING CONCERN FOR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
HE'S BEEN TAKING AS THE
INCREASING THE AMOUNT.
MORE TIME IN LOOKING AT THIS
ISSUE CAN BE IN. SIX MONTHS AND
TO INTO THE POSITION.
THAT.
HE IS LOOKING AT TO AND BECOMING
AN INCREASING CONCERN WITH THE
WITH THE HIGH COST OF LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE RATES ON ON
CONSUMERS.
AND CLEARLY WHEN WE'VE HEARD --
THE THE THE EXAMPLES OF OF OF
THE FROM THE SOME WOMEN AND FROM --
THE PREVIOUS WITNESS THAT TO THE
THE PERSONAL IMPACTS THAT THAT
TO AND ONE OF MANY TOO MANY
STORIES THAT ARE OCCURRING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND NATION.
AND SO IT'S IT REALLY IS TODAY
CONSUMERS WHO CANNOT AFFORD
THESE INCREASE PREMIUMS AND FIND
THEMSELVES LEFT WITH TWO CHOICES
THAT CAN EITHER.
DROP THE POLICY EFFECTIVELY
THROWING AWAY YEARS THE PREMIUMS
PAID AD POTENTIALLY TURNED A
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
LIKE MEDICAID MEDICARE IN
CALIFORNIA OR THEY CAN ACCEPT.
YOUR BENEFITS.
WHICH AMOUNTS TO PAYING MORE FOR
LESS NEITHER OPTION HE BELIEVES
IS PALATABLE AND SO.
THE THE THE COMMISSION BELIEVES
THAT -- IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SOMEONE CALDERON NOW IS THE TIME
TO TURN THE SISTER AROUND.
AND THINK AHEAD BY CREATING
PROGRAMS AND PRODUCTS THAT
DELIVER ON THE PROMISE OF LONG
TERM CARE THAT PROVIDES QUALITY
CARE.
YEARS AND HE BELIEVES THIS TASK
FORCE ENVISIONED IN THIS BILL
WOULD BE A STRONG FIRST STEP
TOWARD BUILDING IN EXPLORING A
ROBUST STATEWIDE.
PUBLIC LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
PROGRAM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS ANOTHER NOTE TO A CUT TO THE
COMMISSIONER JUST RETURNED FROM
A NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS MEETING
JUST LAST WEEK.
ABOUT LTC IN THE WHOLE BULK OF
IT WAS LOOKING AT ALL TO SEE
ADEQUACY RATES WOULD WE DO WITH
ALL OF THESE -- NOW CLOSE BLOCKS
WHICH ARE A TERM THAT'S USED --
FOR LTC POLICIES OF POLICIES
THAT ARE NO LONGER SOLD.
BUT THEY'RE STILL ON THE BOOKS
AND THERE IS A A THOUSANDS OF
POLICY HOLDER STILL THAT ARE
STARTING OUR CONTINUE TO SEE.
IS DOUBLE DIGIT DIGIT INCREASES
AND SO.
IT IS A HUGE QUANDARY NATIONWIDE
FOR INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS
ABOUT THE NATION OF WHAT TO DO
WITH THESE CLOTHES BOX A
BUSINESSES WELL AS TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE UNDER THIS COMMISSIONER
HE CERTAINLY WANTS. TO TO
INCENTIVIZE AND HAVE OF REVIEW
AND APPROVE NEWER PRODUCTS FOR
PLACEMENT ON THE MARKET AND
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE.
MORE LONG TERM CARE.
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE OTHER OPTIONS
TO PROVIDE SO AGAIN BRINGING
BACK TO THIS BILL.
IS THAT TO THE COMMISSION IS
VERY PROUD AND SUPPORTING THIS
BILL IT INSTANTLY WILL GO A LONG
WAY.
I'M AND ALSO VERY -- REMISS IF I
DID ALSO THANK ASSEMBLYMAN.
FOR ACCEPTING ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THAT WE
THOUGHT TO FURTHER WHITE IN THE
TENT.
OF ADDITIONAL LONG TERM CARE
PROVIDERS -- THAT PROVIDE REALLY
VALUABLE SERVICE IN THE LONG
TERM CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM TODAY
SO WITH THAT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS YES
MISTER BURGESS.
IF YOU'RE A WOMAN THIS MORE OF A
KIND OF A HOUSEKEEPING
[inaudible]
PROCEDURAL QUESTION.
SO THIS WOULD CREATE THIS.
STUDY AND I GUESS MY QUESTION
MAYBE.
SB DOES TO YOU.
WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE FOR
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
THROUGH THE INSURANCE
[inaudible]
HARTMAN.
TO HAVE INITIATED THE STUDY ON
ITS OWN.
RATHER THAN GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE HAD.
TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
IS A COMMON FOR US.
TO DEL OF DIRECTLY INTO THESE
APARTMENTS IN THIS FASHION.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I I I
I CAN APPRECIATE WHAT.
FROM I THERE CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN
BILLS PREVIOUSLY -- PERTAIN TO
JUST ANY ISSUE -- WHERE CREE
HELPING AND PARTNER WITH THE
MINISTRATION THIS CASE ITS OWN
STAND?
ALONE -- STATEWIDE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER --
WHETHER ADMINISTRATIVE OR
THROUGH A BILL. FOR THIS CASE
THE COMMISSIONER SUPPORTS THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT REALLY IS A
PARTNERSHIP AND IT DOES PROVIDE
THIS -- THIS OPEN DIALOGUE AND
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE IT REALLY IS
I NEED TO BE A PARTNERSHIP HE
BELIEVES AND SO.
THE CHRISTIAN CREATING THIS THIS
TASK FORCE IN THE STATUTORY
CONSTRUCT OR REPAIR BILL.
HELPS PROVIDE A CAN BUT FOR THE
THAT THAT THAT PARTNERSHIP FROM
DAY.
ONE AND AS YOU KNOW.
FORMER SENATOR LOTT AYE HE COMES
FROM AND AND HE REALLY DOES SEE
IN HIS ROLE AS INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER PARTNERING WITH THE
WALL AND SO HE DOES.
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A A A A A A
A VERY GOOD. FOR STOP AND HAVING
A BILL I AND AND BEING ABLE TO
CAN PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN AND ASSEMBLYMAN AND SENATE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AT I'VE
I'VE AUTHORED A COUPLE OF THESE
BILLS IN THE PAST I MEAN I JUST
PASSED GOT A BILL PASSED LAST
YEAR THE SORT OF WORKING.
GROUP TO TO TO REALLY EXAMINE --
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY IN ITS
EVERYDAY USES IN OUR EVERYDAY
LIFE INCOMES ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE
AND SO GENERALLY LEGISLATURE.
THESE TYPES OF PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THE ONE THING THAT I
WOULD SAY IN TERMS OF THE
BENEFIT OF IT BEING.
COMING IS COMING FROM US IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF US AS AS WELL
AND ALLOWING US TO HAVE A A ROLE
IN WHAT ENDS UP.
COMING GOING INTO THE COMMISSION
AND WHAT COMES OUT OF THE
COMMISSION AND ONE OF THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON EVER
SINCE THE NEW CLASS OF MEMBERS
EXTRA TWELVE YEARS.
IS YOU KNOW THERE WAS A WHAT WE
BELIEVE AN APPLICATION OF A LOT
OF AUTHORITY -- TO DIFFERENT --
WHETHER IT'S STATE BUREAUCRACIES
ARE OTHER AREAS AND SO WHAT WE
TRY TO DO IS MAINTAIN OUR
ABILITY.
TO SERVE AN OVERSIGHT ROLE AND
AND HAVE WHATEVER WE END UP
DOING COME BACK TO US SO THAT WE
CAN.
WEIGH IN ON WHAT THAT PROCESS IS
AND IF THEY'RE IN OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BUY IN FROM THE
BEGINNING.
IT ALLOWS US AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO HAVE MORE OF ANY INTEREST IN
PASSING SOMETHING LATER ON
WHENEVER WE HEAR BACK FROM THE
COMMISSION AND WHATEVER THIS IS
ESTABLISHED AND WE GET THE
REPORT BACK FROM THIS COMMISSION
SPECIFICALLY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
AND LEGISLATURE HAS BY AND HAS
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT BECAUSE
WE ARE THE ONE THAT IS
ESTABLISHED AT THE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
THAT'S RIGHT TO LET IN THE
MISTAKES.
AT THROUGH THE TASK FORCE.
AND I CAN ENVISION BRING IN THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY TOGETHER.
AND CREATING -- PLAN STATEWIDE
PLANS THAT WOULD OPEN UP DOORS
FOR THOSE ARE BECOMING SENIORS
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES -- THOSE
ARE LOOKING FOR A LONG TIME
ALONG CARE A LONG TERM CARE --
SO IS ARE YOU LOOKING ALSO THE
SET DOWN RATES THAN AND TERMS
CONDITIONS IT IS A TASK FORCE
CAN BE LOOKING AT THAT AS WELL I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE MOVING FORWARD WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
BUT I THINK WE'RE STILL.
A LITTLE CONFUSED ON WHAT THE
SOLUTION IS GOING TO BE -- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE DIFFERENT AVENUES
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
OKAY.
ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL WHAT CAN WE
DO.
ESTABLISH SOME TYPE OF A PROGRAM
WHAT WHAT IS THAT'S PRO PROGRAM
GOING TO LOOK LIKE WHAT ARE THE
COSTS GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
YOU KNOW IT WILL FOR GONNA BE
ESTABLISHING RATES WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE GET TALK TO THE
INDUSTRY WHAT CAN THEY DO WHAT
<c.green>AN THEY NOT DO WHO IS GOING TO</c>
BE THE IMPLEMENTOR OF THE
PROGRAM SO.
I MEAN AT THE POINT OF THE TASK
FORCE IS THE ANSWER ALL THAT ALL
THOSE QUESTIONS AND THAT'S
REASON WHY I'M RUNNING THIS BILL
RIGHT NOW.
RATHER THAN A BILL TO ESTABLISH --
WHAT A PROGRAM ACTUALLY WOULD
LOOK LIKE JUST BECAUSE I
COULDN'T ANSWER THAT AND AND AND
I AND I AND I NEED MORE
INFORMATION OR TO TO ESTABLISH
SOMETHING OBVIOUSLY INFORMATION
IS POWER?
MENTION THERE'S ONLY TEN OR
TWELVE I GUESS THE GOAL OF THE
GROW AT ONCE AGAIN. TO REACH
THAT NUMBER OF EIGHTY NINETY
HUNDRED THAT'LL BE PARTICIPATING
WITH THE NEW.
IMPLEMENTATION OF OF OF WHATEVER
WE CAN PUT TOGETHER.
ON THE TABLE THAT WILL SHOWS
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN TODAY'S
WORLD.
YEAH I CONGRATULATE YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS.
THANK YOU CENTER.
BEFORE I GO TO MISS BATES WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO.
YOUR WITH YOUR PRESENT JONES.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA PRESENT.
EIGHT IT'S PRESENT BRIDGES.
IS PRESENT DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI PRESENT CLOSURE HUESO
MITCHELL MORE LOCK PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO PRESENT ROTH.
SORRY DOT.
DOT PRESENT.
NOW WE HAVE A QUORUM.
ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR FOR SHOWING UP --
WE WILL CONTINUE TO OUT CENTER
BATES YOUR NEXT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON -- FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE HERE BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR.
YOU KNOW SAID NO ON THE LAST
ROUND.
THIS IS FOR THAT I THINK WERE OF
CONCERN AND CERTAINLY
LEGITIMIZING.
ARE THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT THE
ABILITY OF A PROGRAM THAT GIVES.
AYE INITIATED THAT THAT'S
TOTALLY GOVERNMENT.
SO GIVE ME SOME RESPONSES AS YOU
GO FORWARD.
HOW YOU WOULD ARE YOU ON THE
AGENDA FOR THIS TASK FORCE WOULD
DEAL WITH A LOT OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COULD BE
THERE ON SOMETHING THAT'S MORE
NOT JUST PUBLIC INSURANCE WITH
MAYBE A PRIVATE?
PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP I SEE THAT AS
A SOLUTION.
OF BECAUSE THE NEW PAYROLL TAX
ON TOP OF PAYROLL TAXES IF OUT
THAT'S THE WAY WE SUPPORT.
A GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS THAT
STARTS TO BE A DIMINISHING.
OF BENEFIT TO THOSE WHO SEE AB
THE YOUNGER AGE YOURS THE MONEY
GOING OUT.
AND YOU'RE GONNA SAY -- WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN I DON'T LIVE LONG
ENOUGH TO NEED LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE AND IT IS VERY
EXPENSIVE?
WE HAVE IT IT IS CERTAINLY LESS
THAN WHAT IT COST YOU.
R. E. N. NOW -- LONG TERM CARE
MY MOTHER WAS AND THAT IT WAS
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH BUT BECAUSE OF A
COMBINATION OF YOU KNOW TENSIONS
THAT SHE HAD AND WHAT MY DAD
PROVIDED FOR WE WERE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THAT.
MIGHT LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
RIGHT NOW RUNS ABOUT TWO TO IT'S
NOT [inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND OUR PERSON.
AND THAT IS CERTAINLY LESS THAN
THE COST OF LONG TERM CARE IF
THAT'S GONNA KICK IN THAT IT HAS
A IT'S BASICALLY LIMITED IN
TERMS OF HOW LONG IT.
YOU KNOW IS TO ALL THOSE THINGS
THE DIMENSIONS THE COMPONENTS OF
THIS TO ME ARE VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK IT'S A VERY NOBLE CAUSE.
BILL QUESTION BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW THAT THE AGENDA FOR THIS-TASK FORCE.
X. THEN A WHOLE -- VETERAN OF
OPPORTUNITY AND IDEAS TO ENSURE
THAT A PROGRAM IS.
GOING TO BE SUSTAINABLE AND WE
KNOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TALKED IT OUT OF THE CA BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF SUSTAINABILITY
THEY BELIEVE FOR A NATIONWIDE
GOVERNMENT.
RUN PROGRAM THAT HAS TO BE PART
OF IT AND KNOWING OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
AND JOB I HAD A VERY --
INTERESTING CONVERSATION GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH HIM TODAY OF
HOW HE'S REALLY ENJOYING.
MOVING AROUND THE STATE IN
HEARING ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
IDEAS AND THE NEEDS THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND HOW WE MEET THEM IN
TERMS OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
INSURANCE THAT EVERY.
ACTUALLY EVERY DIMENSION EVERY
LEVEL OF OUR LIVES SO WHAT I'M
GONNA DO TODAY THAT'S KIND OF A
STATEMENT AND A QUESTION.
I DID VOTE NO LAST TIME AND I'M
NOT VOTING NO THIS TIME BUT I'M
GONNA LAY OFF BECAUSE I WOULD
LIKE.
YOU TO SPEND SOME TIME.
ARE THINKING ABOUT HOW.
A CHEN DIES THEN HOW YOU RESPOND
TO WHAT.
OF THE OUR GOVERNOR BROWN SAID
IN HI VETO MESSAGE WILL START
WITHOUT ISSUE BROUGHT IT BACK.
YOU DIDN'T AGREE WITH HIM IN IS
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME.
SO WHAT DO YOU SEE IS THE NEW
WAY TO APPROACH THIS THAT.
OUR ANSWERS HIS CONCERN AND
CERTAINLY THE FEDERAL.
ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION ME I MEAN.
MY THE BIGGEST CONCERN I HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS THE FACT THAT.
IT'S AN UNSUSTAINABLE SOLUTION
WHERE YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
HAVE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
THEY NEED NAY IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY NEED LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE OTHER SPENDING DOWN
THEIR ASSETS IN ORDER.
TO QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL AND I I
JUST.
THAT IS IN A SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM
MOVING FORWARD I ASSUME NOTHING
IN THE THE CREATION OF THIS TASK
FORCE I DON'T.
I'M NOT POINTING IN A SPECIFIC
DIRECTION FOR THIS TO GO WHAT
I'M TRYINGTO DO IS PUT THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OF PEOPLE IN THE
RIGHT COLLECTION OF PEOPLE ON A
TASK FORCE TO BE ABLE TO END UP
WITH THE BEST PRODUCT.
I DON'T HAVE A VESTED INTEREST
IN WHAT THAT PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE
I HAVE A VESTED INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER THE
SUGGESTIONS ARE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ULTIMATELY GOING
TO MAKE A DECISION ON IS.
THE MOST UP TO DATE BEST
POSSIBLE SOLUTION MOVING FORWARD
TAKING ALL OF THOSE FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION TAKING COST
INDIVIDUAL.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ISSUES THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IMPACT PUBLIC
SECTOR IMPACT I MEAN IF.
IT'S GONNA BE THE ANSWER IF IT'S
IT IS PRIVATE IF IT'S JOINT THEN
IT IS JOINT I I I AM NOT MARRIED.
AT ANY IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM
TO ANY SPECIFIC OUTCOME I JUST
WANT THE BEST OUTCOME BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY IT'S NOT MY JOB TO
SAY I WANT SOMETHING
SPECIFICALLY.
IT'S MY JOB TO BE GET GET THE
RIGHT ANSWER AND THEN.
TRY TO CONVINCE YOU OF THAT THAT
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
MOVING FORWARD.
THE SENATOR IS SENATOR GALGIANI.
I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I HAVE
TWO PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY CLOSE TO
ME LIKE ADOPTED PARENTS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO THIS RIGHT NOW
WHERE WE'RE TRYING.
TO COME UP WITH A PLAN FOR THEM
IN SIX MONTHS AND WHILE IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES IS A WONDERFUL --
SERVICE TO HAVE IT DOESN'T WORK
ALL THE TIME FOR ALL STAGES FOR
EVERYONE AND JUSTIN IN STOCKTON
FOR EXAMPLE FOR A A TWO BEDROOM
INDEPENDENT LIVING PLACE IT'S
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED A MONTH.
PLUS SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS FOR THE SECOND
PERSONAND WHILE THAT INCLUDES
ALL YOUR MEALS IT'S CLEARLY.
OUT OF REACH FOR MANY MANY
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHEN IT'S MORE
OF AN INDEPENDENT LIVING
SITUATION AS OPPOSED TO NEEDING
ASSISTED LIVING WITH.
WITH MEDIC.
AND THEN AND DRESSING AND
BATHING AND AND THINGS LIKE THAT
SO I REALLY THANK YOU FOR
PURSUING THIS I THINK THAT -- WE
NEED TO AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED.
TO THINK IN TERMS OF AFFORDABLE
INDEPENDENT LIVING SITUATIONS
FOR SENIORS.
AND WE HAVE A BABY BOOMER
GENERATION WHO IS AGING OUT TO
BE WELL.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR PLACES. FOR THEM TO GO AND
RECEIVE.
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED SO THAT
ALSO NEEDS TO BE A PIECE OF OF
WHAT THIS TASK FORCE LOOKS LIKE
AND I HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU ARE MOVED BY MISTRUST
LETTER BUT BEFORE WE DO I WANT
TO JUST -- MAKE COMMENTS ON IT I
THINK YOU KNOW AS TO MISTER
MARTINEZ MENTION IT'S A GREAT
FOR STAFF.
AND I REALLY DO -- I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT YOU'RE TAKING
SUGGESTIONS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CONCERN ME JUST INITIALLY.
NOT I'M A BIG CONCERN BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT BOARD
MAKE UP THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE ENTIRE STATE.
YOUR FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS I AM AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONCERNS AND COMPLAINTS
I HEAR A LOT IS THAT SOMETIMES
WE TEND.
TO FILL THOSE SLOTS WITH EITHER
NORTHERN OR SOUTHERN AND THEN WE
HAVE THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT
GETS LEFT OUT STILL.
IN PEOPLE FROM EVERY SECTOR
EVERY SINGLE OUT GEOGRAPHIC.
AREA FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN WHEREVER IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE EVERYONE DEALS
WITH DIFFERENT ISSUES
DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEY'RE AT AND SO JUST WANT TO
SEE IF YOU WOULD CONSIDER THAT
MOVIE FOR MAKING SURE WE AT
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW. FOR
DIFFERENT REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA
TO BE REPRESENTED I HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT AND IN A MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AND YOUR AND AND YOUR
STAFF TO FIND THE PROPER
LANGUAGE TO STRESS THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU END UP MISTER TO THEM
WITH THE BILL THESE [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
MR -- CALDERON WHICH YOU WISH TO
CLOSE I I APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE.
ARM YOU KNOW I'M NOT LOOKING TO
TO BE TRADITIONAL WHEN IT COMES
TO SOLVING THIS PROBLEM I THINK
WE NEED TO BE.
CAPACITY IN THE RIGHT KIND OF
MEMBERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES TO DO
SO -- AND I THINK THAT THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
START WORKING ON IT. TO TAKE THE
FIRST STEP TO START WORKING ON
AN ISSUE THAT IS ONLY GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DETERIORATE AND GET
WORSE -- AND SO THE TIME IS NOW
TO ACT.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FROM A BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEEN MOVE MY ARCHULETA MISSION
IS TO PASS.
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
HI I JONES.
ARCHULETA BUT TO LET AYE BATES
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE LEISURE LEISURE I
HUESO MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH -- I'M I PUT
THE BALL ON CALL -- SEVEN VOTES --
SIX WILL BE ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON [inaudible]
AND SOME.
THE NEXT BILL IS AB.
ELEVEN OH FOUR ALSO BY A SEMI
CALDERON YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB LEVEL FOR WILL ADD TO
PUBLIC MEMBERS TO THE BOARD --
OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE AND
HEALTH INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
CLICK -- TO AND CREATE AN
ASSESSMENT TO FIND FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT.
OF LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
COMPANIES DON'T JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS THE COMPANY'S ASKING FOR
THIS ON ON THEIR OWN.
I ASKING FOR THE FEE TO TO DO
THIS ON THE ROUND AND WORK
BROADENING OF THE BOARD AND AND
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR WHAT KLAY
GET IS CLICK A IS THE ASSOCIATE.
IT'S BASICALLY A GUARANTEE FINE
SO.
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
SAY E. PROPERLY ARE YOU DIDN'T
MAKE PROPER ASSESSMENT IN TERMS
OF WHAT YOU CHARGE FOR YOUR
POLICIES YOU GO OUT OF BUSINESS
WELL THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN PAYING FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME. TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF
TO HAD TO HAVE THE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE NOW THE QUESTION
IS WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM WELL
KLIEG EXIST SO THAT IN THE EVENT
THAT SOMEBODY GOES OUT OF
BUSINESS.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE NOW
LEFT IN LARGE WITHOUT A PLAN.
HAVE A GUEST GUARANTEE
ASSOCIATION THAT ALL THE
PROVIDERS.
PAY INTO THE COVER THE COSTS
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THAT
PLAN.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A
SHORE THAT UP AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUES EXISTING
IN X. THE CURRENT FORM ALTHOUGH
THIS GOING TO MEAN MORE WORK
THAT'S GONNA BE NEEDED FOR ITS
LONG TERM SUCCESS IN BY ABILITY.
ARE CURRENTLY CLEAR HIS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS IS ONLY MADE UP OF
INSURANCE INDUSTRY INDIVIDUALS
AND THERE ARE NO NON INSURANCE
INTEREST INDUSTRY INTERESTS --
FEST REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
INTERESTS OF THE PUBLIC AT LARGE
NOT JUST THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
ARE PART OF THE DELIBERATIONS OF
CLICK ON ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
INCLUDES AN ASSESSMENT TO FUND
THE REPORTS.
LAST YEAR IS AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY FIVE MANDATED.
Là AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE
MAN THAT REQUIRE THE DEPARTMEN
OF INSURANCE TO CONDUCT
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT
OF LONG TERM CARE INSURERS.
THESE NEW FILING.
ARE DESIGNED TO ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL
POSITION OF LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE AND HOPEFULLY ACT
EARLY ENOUGH TO HEAD OFF
POTENTIAL IN SOLVENT SEAS.
THIS ASSESSMENT WAS NEGOTIATED
OVER THE FALL BETWEEN THE
INDUSTRY IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND ENJOYS.
SUPPORT FROM BOTH OF THOSE
INTERESTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT IS MIKE MONTANUS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
SHERRY IF.
WITH ACT LIKE IF SHE'S AROUND.
MARTINEZ GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL
MARTINEZ DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
ODDLY IS SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND ABSOLUTE TRUTH WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MINUTES SAID SO IT'S
REALLY JUST.
HE HAD A MEASURE LAST YEAR THAT
WAS ENACTED THAT WOULD MANDATE
INSURERS TO FILE.
A REPORT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
THIS BILL NOW BEFORE YOU WOULD
ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO RECOUP
OUR COST TO ABLE TO MAKE SURE.
THAT -- REALLY THE DIESEL LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE COMPANIES --
TO MEET -- ANNUALLY ASSESS THEM
AS WELL AS TO PREVENT MORE LTC
COMPANY INSOLVENCY IS AND
ULTIMATELY PROTECT CONSUMERS SO
WE ARE AND ALSO WITH THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS ON THE CLEAR BOARD
SUPPORT THAT THAT -- ELEMENT OF
THE BILL AS WELL AND SO WITHOUT
A STRUGGLE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD -- MEMBERS JOHN TREATING
ON BEHALF ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES.
USE THE TIRE TODAY HAD A MINOR
SURGERY -- BUT WHY TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY THINK THIS I MEMBER
AND THE DEPARTMENT -- FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL --
THE GOOD BILL THIS AS MANY AS IS
NEEDED AND IT'S GONNA PROVIDE
ENHANCED OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY WHAT'S GOING ON SO
LONG TERM CARE MARKET AND WE
JUST HEARD FROM.
THE PRIOR BILL THERE'S A LOT
GOING ON THERE AND IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE FIGHTING.
IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THE NINE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS.
MOVED BY MISTER FOR JUST PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MY MISSION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RUBIO.
I RUBIO AYE JONES.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRIDGES.
WE'RE JUST AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
FRAZIER I HUESO MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
WE HAVE.
EIGHT WE HAVE EIGHT HOUR GONNA
PLACE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YOUR TIME AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA.
IF THE CALL ON I GUESS
EVERYONE'S EXCITED TO SEE A AND
WESSEL COME TODAY WELCOME MR
WESSEL.
WE'RE GONNA LIVE THE KANYE BE
FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WEBER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS IT WAS MOVED
BY BRIDGES RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO AYE JONES.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS.
GORGEOUS BUT I BRIDGES I DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER LEISURE AYE
HUESO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
SINCE YOU KNOW ON A ROCK.
THE THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES WERE
GONNA PLACED AT THE LONG CALL AT
THIS TIME I'M GONNA LEFT A CALL
ON AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERS TO HEALTH COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO JONES
[inaudible] EIGHT OR JUST.
HUESO.
HUESO I MITCHELL.
MORE LARK RIGHT [inaudible]
YES [inaudible] SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO WE'RE GONNA PLACE THE
BILL CALL WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS TO ENSURE.
SO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA MOVE ONTO
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO I'M GONNA OPEN UP FOR AT A BI
LEVEL FOR A THOMAS WESSEL.
TO VOTE.
AND MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS HUESO
[inaudible]
HUESO AYE.
WE'RE GONNA PLAY THE BONE CALL
WITH NINE VOTES WERE GONNA MOVE
ONTO CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOTION BY MISTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AB.
EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE JONES ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BURGESS.
WE'RE JUST AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HUESO.
WE SAW AYE MITCHELL MORE LOCK
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
THAT HAS NINE VOTES WERE GONNA
PLACE THE THAT ON CALL AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TEN
MINUTE RECESS OUR MOST OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE BUDGET COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW.
SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN OUR ANALYST
A CALL ON EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN TO ALLOW MR MORE LIKE TO
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIRTY SEVEN ZERO MORE LOCK.
AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN GOT THAT ON
YES.
MORE LIKE NO.
WE'RE GONNA PLACE THE BILL LONG
KERR WE'RE GONNA LIVE THE CALL
ON A. B.. ONE ONE ZERO FOUR
CALDERON PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THE PAST TWO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTERS NINE
ZERO MORE LOCK.
AB.
ELEVEN FOR CAN WE JUST HAVE --
SIGN IS JUST FOR A LITTLE BIT SO
WE CAN GET THESE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ELEVEN OH
FOUR CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MORLOCK [inaudible]
MOORLACH I ENTER.
WE'RE GONNA PLACE THE BILL ON
HOLD.
ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB. FIFTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT FIVE MOTION IS TO
PASS PRINTED IS NINE ZERO MORE
LOCK.
MOORLACH I JONES.
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WEBER TO
PASS.
CURRENT VOTE [inaudible] ELEVEN
WE'RE GONNA PUT IN A THE VOTE IS
ELEVEN ZERO WE'RE GONNA PLACED
ON CALL -- I'VE BEEN ADVISED
THAT ALL FOUR MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE ARE AND BUDGET SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TEN MINUTE
RECESS.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO CONSENT
CALENDAR A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN NINETEEN AB.
FOURTEEN KERN IS [inaudible]
NINE OH JONES [inaudible]
CAN CENTERS ELEVEN ZERO SINCE WE
HAVE MISTER JOHN.
JOHNSON AB JOIN AS WE'RE GONNA
LET THE CALL ON A. B. FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN CALDERON [inaudible]
YOU.
JONES.
JONES NOW.
THE VOTE IS SEVEN TWO WERE IN A
PLACE TO BELONG CALL -- I'M
GONNA HAVE TO CALL ON A. B.
ELEVEN ALL FOR CALDERON.
CURRENT VOTERS TEND TO ZERO
JONES.
JONES I THE VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO
WE'RE GONNA PLAY IS THE BILL
BACK ON CALL [inaudible]
BUT WHAT.
OKAY SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE.
TO TAKE UP. SEVEN OR EIGHT
MINUTE RECESS UNTIL A BUDGET IS
CONCLUDED AND DIE WITHOUT WILL
OPEN UP IT UP AGAIN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE ARE GOING TO OPEN UP THE
COMMITTEE MEETING WE HAVE OUR
TWO MISSING MEMBERS AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA.
OPEN A LIFT THE CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR AB. ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT AB EIGHT ONE EIGHT
ONE THREE AB ONE EIGHT ONE FOUR
HE'S CALL THE WRONG.
IT IS.
ELEVEN ZERO MORE LAST HIS ME
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT. THIRTEEN ZERO
MAX WE'RE GONNA MOVE LEFT THE
CON AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN CALDERON
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT RESEARCH SEVEN TWO
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE ROTH.
I THE BILL IS OUT NINETY TWO OUR
NEXT WE'RE GONNA LET THE CALL ON
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WBER.
IS COLORADO.
KERN VOTERS ELEVEN ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE ROTH [inaudible]
LEVINE.
THE BELLS OUT THIRTEEN ZERO NEXT
FOR MOVING ONTO A. B. ELEVEN ALL
FOR CAL [inaudible]
THE ROW.
IT IS ELEVEN ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE ROTH.
HI.
THE BILL IS OUT THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU EVERYONE HAVE A THANK
YELL AND THIS CONCLUDES THE
COMMITTEE HAVE A WONDERFUL
AFTERNOON
[inaudible]
YOU